let me tell you about my favorite game
of all time the game I always look back
to with fond memories like meeting my
first girlfriend that's not a lie by the
way the game I wasted my teenage years
on where I should have been out tibia
7.6 baby a 7.6 is important because T
bear today is now a [ __ ] garbage
don't watch this video and be like Oh
Chiba I better check that game out it
sounded pretty cool to me explain it no
no it's just like World of Warcraft if
you say you loved World of Warcraft
you're not talking about it today you're
talking about vanilla [ __ ] Wow now
chances are you are you heard a tibia
before which basically means you're
either there polish Brazilian or Swedish
cuz those were the only people playing
the game for some reason beg beards
I am Romanian and I heard about the game
shut up but dudes this game looks just
like a runescape copy
shut shut up myth beards this game is
not as good as World of Warcraft hey
listen here you piece of [ __ ]
tibia two balls of steel to play tibia
made me a man the man the great man I am
today
Wow it's for [ __ ] [ __ ] I played
yo2 and I really enjoyed it by the way
but still let me tell you why if you die
in the game any game what happens you
respawn oh that's cute you respawn you
take you a second uh-huh that's that's
cute
you die in TIFIA it's like dying in real
life there's like matrix why am I so
excited if you die in tibia you lose
days of [ __ ] work but you're like
okay I'm gonna spend all weekend to
level up my character
Felix town Boston means Felix toothbrush
great [ __ ] name I know I spend all
weekend
leveling up I literally spent 24 hours
probably in total and then all the
sudden all that [ __ ] work is just
gone because some [ __ ] came in
out of nowhere but while I was farming
my [ __ ] root worms anyone could kill
you in this game at any point no matter
what level you are there's no limit the
tibia there's no max level limit there's
no skill level limit
there's no item limit and let me tell
you there's no [ __ ] limit and you
know when you're a kid and you're just a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that was me in this game so at least I
had I had a safe space to practice my
immoral deeds you know so please don't
judge me for what I'm about to tell you
cuz he might change your view on me I
was so hated
while playing tibia feeling somewhat shy
and my other many other characters I was
always hated my friend it was a thing
like my friends were always so shocked
like why are you always so hated by
everyone like even my friends were like
we can't be associated with you because
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and everyone
hates you whenever I started doing
YouTube I was literally shocked that
anyone liked what I was doing that was
such a new thing to me imagine me as a
teenager like I'm annoying enough as 27
remember the Brazilians bless your soul
I'm sorry for one of them about to say
but you're not very good at English some
of you hey hey and I'm sorry okay sis it
bad what's the case that is not my
[ __ ] fault in this game it's not like
[ __ ] wow where you have to oh I gonna
trade an item oh I'll just send it over
move over done okay no you'd have to
meet up in person in the game and it was
a huge level map okay you'd have to go
from one city to another you'd be like
okay alright we should are you in oh I'm
in tights oh [ __ ] well I can't I can't
come right now okay fine I'll meet you
there alright so you figured it out and
once you're next to each other you would
have to have the amount of money on you
and the other person would have the item
so I would tell this poor Brazilians hey
make me buy the King entice alright
it'll be that's a great spot not a lot
of people is there it's okay it's a good
way to put a trade but but I want to
trade in the deposit store like normal
oh no no no no you want to go to the
king it's way better it's way better to
trade next to the king Baek come on come
on it's nice and cool no one is there
it's a great spot to make a tray
a lot of people didn't know about was
that if you swear in front of the king
you would lose all your health it's so
stupid right but that's the thing about
tibia it's [ __ ] dumb they would
initiate the trade right but I would
cancel and be like no no no no no I am
very I'm a very formal man write down
this accept rate and they would be like
I don't understand I just write it out
not privately publicly accept rate it's
just the way I do business and there'd
be like accept rate no you're doing
great buddy you're doing excellent
you're almost there now just say [ __ ]
[ __ ] the King and the game gets pissed
up census guard he gets he gets to one
health I come in come in with my little
dagger poke that [ __ ] whoop he's dead
easy job didn't even have to waste
anything and the best [ __ ] part is
that he brought all the gold for the
trade because you don't just lose a
level oh no no you lose your [ __ ]
Luke and I haven't told you about the
best part
the Brazilian incoherent rage babble
what did you do ah why am i I sound like
such an ass up it was so fun it was just
so funny to see all the messes private
messages pop up like you're [ __ ] dead
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you before you
hear me and you're already out of there
you're far away it was the best of time
my character Felix toothbrush I know
great [ __ ] name it was pretty high
level and I'll tell you why we cheated
the [ __ ] out of the game we were bought
in 24 hours a day I know I've been an
[ __ ] before but bahding it's like
cheating and cheating is bad and you
shouldn't do it
but we did it out of all things that I
said before blotting was the best thing
[ __ ] ever I want it back in my life
for those of you don't know what botting
is it basically means you were running a
cheat that would move your character
kind of like in a circle and killing the
same monsters over and over and over and
over
and loot all their [ __ ] so basically
once you woken up you see like your
backpacks are just [ __ ] filled with
gold and can't even fit anymore and that
was the best [ __ ] thing ever waking
up in the morning was like Christmas
every [ __ ] day it was like [ __ ]
cocaine and I need that [ __ ] again but
of course there was some man that was
that what though there were some things
that happened some people didn't like
that you bought it because they would
like approach you and be like hey and if
you didn't respond they would know that
you were biting because typically if
they see that you're moving around for a
long [ __ ] time um it was pretty
obvious well don't you worry about it
because I had a script that would reply
if they wrote hi I would be like hi
sorry very busy looting a lot it would
create killing a lot of root worms over
here but thank you for saying hi if they
asked hey what's 2+2 I'd be like 4 by
but of course sometimes they would
figure it out anyway all right it wasn't
flawless but it worked but I had an
alarm okay so if someone would attack me
and try and kill me
I had an alarm all right and let me tell
you the PTSD that I have from Medellin
so I obviously couldn't just have the
alarm on full volume during a night
because I would wake up my parent so I
would sleep with my headphones which
surprisingly wasn't that bad like I
slept very nice knowing that my bot was
doing all the work for me but one night
the alarm went on and I would literally
throw myself out of bed like it there
was no hesitation it was like Oh daddy
I'm going running to the [ __ ]
computer and then you see that the alarm
has been going on for a long [ __ ]
time because all my health packs are
gone I've used up all of them my bot
would take care of that as well and I
saw the last health bar go away and that
would die and there was no way I would
sleep that night single-tier never has
anything effect you know what in real
life as well nothing has met ever made
me so upset as when I died by that bot
I'll never forget you Lord elder Quist
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so I would have a couple different
characters and whenever I got to a high
level I would get so [ __ ] cocky and
[ __ ] that what people would just
start start killing literally people
from other servers would come over just
to kill me they wouldn't just kill me
they would they would take my corpse and
they would drag it to the center of the
town where everyone could see the
humiliation I'm not faking them legit
sad that it was horrible
my friend saw and they were like watch
dude we can't be friends anymore
I have so many great [ __ ] stories
from that game so many great memories
tibia was great because there was no
restrictions there's really no games
like it out today and even in World of
Warcraft and any MMO or any game in
general they have no consequences that
it doesn't really matter the flaws of
tibia was its strongest bits because it
was so exploitable which made it so much
fun and I don't think I'll ever have an
experience
a game like I had with tibia 7.6 and I
think everyone has a game from their
childhood that they or teenage years
that they really attached himself to and
tibia was definitely that game for me
I'm sure you had a game like that as
well if you did let me know in the
comments and and why thank you for
letting me talk about tibia it means a
lot to me because I the do topic to my
heart leave a like if you enjoyed
listening and I'll see Bruce in the next
video
breakfast